we got some relationship advice this is
Angela from Spring Oklahoma oh she
sounds beautiful
Oh chest snakes in the front my guy that
I was with for two years your robot we
just recently broke up Oh constantly
cheated
oh he's not the only one every guy
before him that I've been with has felt
the need to wander off yeah it doesn't
matter what I do
keeping up with the house making sure
foods on the table keeping up with my
cells but I always come back hold on
it's sorry Brendan wants to starve at
home obviously the start over let's go
back to the middle this lady Oh
nineteen fifties house watch on the
table
I was just spotless I don't say much
what he wants she's just holding the
mail she's like the only what it says I
don't have to Kate myself housewife this
is what she likes to do be at home do
recipes take care of the house take care
of the kids
well that's [ __ ] ain't working
oh my god get me out of this man like
I'm gonna Dave in Buster's and the
power's out brothers still plaguing all
the games I still kick in the ticket
machine wonder why the tickets aren't
coming out who cares why they're not
coming out take seventy thousand tickets
to get a damn whistle you idiot
alright let's let this poor lady finish
okay I don't what I do
keeping up with myself making sure
things say exciting role playing in the
bedroom don't yeah but they always come
back that's the thing oh oh so I'm just
wondering what makes them gonna wander
in the first place
tell me something good gang gang I think
he said buzz bust I think it'd be on the
end of it no you broke you used to
adjustment after you condemn this lady's
lifestyle I'd love to see how you gonna
dig yourself out of this shovels in the
front do dig yourself out of this
[ __ ] you put yourself in Devils in
the front shovels in the bag man they
always come back I don't know man maybe
they take her for granted and they're
just not trying to [ __ ] with or maybe
she's just too good then I got she might
be overwhelming it's how it should have
her own [ __ ] going on get a hobby get
less tattoos you know I'm saying well
you don't like to Brendan you will all
do that we'll just stop getting a maybe
although I think they're sexy okay then
while you say that then she is from a
spring Oklahoma who sprung out there
doing that Brokeback [ __ ] and then come
back after the up to those storm well
that's a no that's a not even a good
idea I don't think but what I will say
is this and I'm sorry it's a good idea
but I just don't think that that's
accurate
what I'm thinking is if these guys are
leaving well maybe you'll have too many
doors on your house or apartment you
know time I've taken people prisoner
know if people can get out easily don't
think I'm prisoner but don't put four
doors on your house but here's main be
upset if your spouse leaves they can
[ __ ] get out he's confused
yeah you're one door I don't even do a
back door you come in the front you go
out the front one door doing was in the
front doors in the front we're making so
many goddamn pies sounds like she's
cooking all the time maybe it's
overwhelming for the dude maybe you need
to mix it up start going out on him
we're making apple pies cherry pies
rhubarb pecan pumpkin one pie a week one
pie a week Netflix and chill she seems
like an older soul does she
nope nope you are just a real strange
guy man come on bro don't touch me do
not talk let me do such a hot look I
think maybe I don't know what do you
guys think
let's go to cab maybe let's get a woman
perspective let's also talk to Derrick
as well you know oh yeah dude I mean
definitely she's providing way too much
to these guys yeah do that especially
when you're younger they get too
comfortable start taking you for granted
how do you hold is she
capturing how old is she yeah if you're
19 homeboys coming down you got a
seven-course meal you dressed like a 50s
housewife and he got [ __ ] you know
yet you hold it you two you're doing too
much you're scaring everybody away it
sounds like yeah you're just going out
the alley and one of those seven doors
you have in your house yeah I'm a little
fun easy yeah maybe uh yeah I don't know
okay she may be chasing guys who just
aren't ready to settle down the same way
she is too cuz she's hot yeah that's
true he's young maybe she's ready for
something that younger guys around her
age aren't ready for older soul exactly
do you what'd he think I think she
definitely hooks up with the
dudes who attract a lot of girls so stop
that [ __ ] a Seth Rogen looking
[ __ ]
yeah who's gonna be grateful Betty's
look at you you know what I mean and I
bet that problems done and then if that
guy cheats on you then it's definitely
you
you know what I mean read a book or
something you think it get ugly dude
Shades of Grey sure you're [ __ ] the
same guy over and over again and that's
why they keep cheat you talking about
that bad boy hitter that boy well
doesn't that pipe game yeah there's a
whole spectrum to you if you get a guy
that's all about looks or something like
that then you might you know you know it
might not get a guy that as much harder
as much like you know gratitude or
anything like that so you got to kind of
even the scale out it's like if you get
a ten and looks then they're gonna be a
seven and some you know it's all it's
all relative it's all evens out you know
you won that's why you want to get that
eight you want to find an eight the hard
a that harder they don't go for the 10
[ __ ] boy yeah they're down eight Tianna
date get that date yeah date an eight
day mate cuz everybody can be an eight
here's the thing everybody can be an
eight if they take care of themselves
believe that but I like really liked how
positive you are an eight and eight you
know I'm saying anybody can be a five
but in eight know if you brush your
teeth
and you and you I think have you know a
little bit of insight the right yes I'm
self-awareness address well-being a I
think a high she can be as a six Dan
yeah God doesn't give me one good looks
bro trust me I know dude I know you know
okay but look what you've done with your
stuff dude I'm cross-eyed but both of
them are in the st. they're both the
straight cross yeah yeah you like a
chameleon
yes crossed on the inside on the outside
it looks fine shut up to this thing I
hope she figures out quit [ __ ] with
him [ __ ] boys though that's the problem
well I don't know if we didn't help that
woman I feel like we did though
[Music]
nothing
[Music]